[Musique]
deux gammes de galgon soir des idoles de
beaucoup de gens en france et surtout
d'hélène ségara ici voilà il est la
touche et le hélène touché le voilà elle
a deux idoles dans sa vie c'est orlando
et vous donc voilà alors c'est vous qui
l'avez eue c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée
du nom depeche mode a malheureusement
oui c'est bon alors c'est le nom d'un
magazine de mode français pourquoi pas
elles ou marie claire oui effectivement
on aurait pu prendre les autres j'étais
écolier à l'époque j'ai j'ai étudié en
fait la mode et on avait fait un concert
petit concert dans un pop à londres
et puis nous n'avions pas encore de nom
alors il y avait ces magazines devant
nous la high tech et puis le team
demander quel est le nom du groupe
c'est le premier magazine que j'ai pris
j'ai 10 dh dans les règles c'est
peut-être nul marie claire quand même
alors des bêches mode c'était des
pionniers vous avez été les premiers à
rendre populaire la musique électronique
kraftwerk avant vous avait initié la
musique électronique mais il l'avait
fait d'une façon très robotique et vous
une façon beaucoup plus acoustique
beaucoup plus facile pour le public on
peut dire oui c'est vrai que nous avons
pris un peu de ces éléments vers les
autres et et qu'on pouvait faire du
bruit à partir d'autre chose qu'une
guitare la batterie
à propos n'étaient pas de très bon
guitariste ses synthétiseurs et tout ça
nous ont permis de manipuler le sont de
manière intéressante
voilà alors l'année de l'apogée de
depeche mode le climax du groupe comme
on dit c'est 1988 en 1985 j'ai sorti un
album qui s'appelait music for my 6
music pour les masses
ensuite il ya une tournée qui s'appelait
tort formé six tournées pour les pour
les masses vous avez acquis à ce moment
là une célébrité mondiale et le 101ème
concerts de cette tournée qui était live
at the rose bowl a été filmée par
pennebaker et il sort en dvd
avec des interviews de membres du groupe
a ensuite extraordinaire c'est
pennebaker il est célèbre pour un film
qui s'appelle montrer pop qui l'a fait
en 1967 qui était un film sur la grande
époque baba il n'avait jamais entendu
parler de depeche mode quand on lui a
proposé de faire un film sur le groupe
et puis il a commencé à s'y coller il a
été fasciné par vous et par vaux femmes
il vous a suivi dans une tournée aux
états unis et il a filmé le 101ème
concert au rose bowl donc été un peu le
climax l'apothéose du groupe on peut
dire manche mais en fait c'est surtout
un documentaire sur les femmes puissent
les gens qui est plutôt que sur nous
mêmes et ce qui était intéressant c'est
de voir justement toute cette
accumulation ces gens qui venaient nous
voir comme des fidèles à l'église
pratiquement qui nous suivait à travers
le pays
et c'est ça qu'il a voulu montrer dans
son documentaire je pense pas que les
gens bien pris la chose au moment du
documentaire des réseaux on l'a critiqué
pour ça mais c'est justement de 5 francs
même film il paraît de plus de 5 e de
depeche mode c'est elle qui
s'intéressait à ses fruits dès que le
public se faisaient qu'à partir de rien
il y avait ce tte eu cette machine à on
avait créé ce truc énorme qui avait la
publicité de la radio mais rien d'autre
pas t'aider
et ça c'était intéressant pardon bruno
on disait qu'il y avait deux classes de
look dans son phrasé non plus efficace
que l'accent texan
oui j'ai réclamé même même il ya une
classe folle prédit vous invite les
femmes qui le voient pas en vrai j'ai
trouvé encore mieux mais enfin il est
trop vieux
en cause un like you girl a pas de
problème elle est bonne voire un divan
dans pas longtemps et le quatrième le
voilà alors vous belga vous étiez la
voix de depeche mode donc pendant 22 ans
et vous avez sorti en mai dernier un
album solo qui s'appelle peppers
monsters faut que je touche qui était
écrit par chez nous alors que
généralement les morceaux étaient écrits
par martin gore
alors j'en avais un peu marre d'ailleurs
de l'hégémonie de martin gore chaussures
le groupe depeche mode
vous avez marre d'être seulement une
voie d'être seulement la voix du groupe
et vos idées de chansons étaient
rarement présent en considération dans
le groupe un petit peu comme george
harrison dans les beatles d'une certaine
façon c'est pas les comparaisons et
justin leov isu qui avait un peu de ça
quand même
sauf que j'en ai un petit peu assez de
voir que je pense que nous avons créée
pour nous mêmes pourquoi on a passé
suffisamment d'années dans un but en or
que tu vas prendre les choses et de voir
que finalement les rôles sont presque
stéréotypé et que sur le plan créatif
finalement nous n'essayons rien de
nouveau parce que nous étions cantonales
ainsi qu'aux sorte à l'étiquette que les
nous étions donné effectivement j'ai
écrit des chansons et puis je me suis
dit que déjà depeche mode est convoité
et elle est toujours être là s'il
fallait faire un album il fallait que ce
soit avec d'autres personnes autour un
succès il fallait me jeter un défi
abonnés et j'ai eu la chance avant
l'aspect occasion de le faire
oui vous avez bien un petit peu marre
d'être utilisée comme un instrument
votre voie utilisée comme un instrument
par le groupe
alors vous avez déclaré d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui l'avenir du groupe depeche
mode dépend de l'attitude de martin gore
parce que on a compris si vous laisse
pas place et plus de chansons avoue on
se dirige vers le split n'a pas parlé en
ces termes là mais j'ai vu partir tout
récemment à los angelès viviano de mes
concerts elle a trouvé ça bien
on n'a pas parlé tellement de depeche
mode il me semble que maintenant je me
suis ouvert une porte un mauvais et j'ai
beaucoup aimé ce que j'ai vu cette page
avec groupe
nous allons bientôt jouer ensemble et je
peux pas je peux plus revenir en arrière
donc si je continue à aller de l'avant
la musique est bien survécu
je fais la musique est prêt à se
partager sa destinée en quelque sorte
alors que les années que j'ai voulu
participer groupe et je suis fier que sa
carrière au cette dépêche mode bébé a
aussi l'appui de mon groupe
alors l'album s'appelle peppers monsters
les monstres de papier est le premier
single s'appelle i need you
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
desgagnés paper monsters ces monstres de
papier dont vous parlez en fait vous
dites que c'est des monstres que vous
vous étiez créer vous même c'est la
drogue c'est l'alcool et vous aussi
comme pierre botton vous êtes guéri
warnock je ne sais pas si je suis guéri
je crois pas qu'on puisse vraiment guéri
il y à vraiment de guérison guérison
mais disons que j'ai beaucoup changé de
choses dans ma vie c'est de cette façon
je crois qu'on peut dire que disons que
je peux m'identifier un petit peu
monsieur bouton d'imagés s'appliquer
beaucoup de sous donc les monstres oui
je parle surtout de déclin des angoisses
et le fait de pouvoir et de pouvoir
faire face à ses angoisses y faire des
choses qu'on n'aurait pas parce qu'on a
créé justement des monts sutton soi même
on se cache derrière ces bons soumah
tendance à se cacher d air frais puis un
jour il faut quand même dépasser cela
alors votre ville est différente
maintenant vous lever tôt
vous accompagnez votre fils à l'école
vous faites de la gymnastique vous fait
du jogging le fisc vous faites de
pierres brûlantes
vous faites des exercices vocaux enfin
tout ce à quoi est-ce que vous avez
c'est bien c'est bien parce qu'en plus
je vais vous dire vous avez quand même
je pense que vous avez pris je sais pas
quelle quantité vous avez pris de drogue
et d'alcool dans tous les cas c'est
vachement bien
c'est bien conserver ce trop gay
c'est vrai il est arrivé je suis dit
voilà ça c'est le seul problème de ces
groupes dans les années 80 un psy qui
n'ont pas vécu comme les z deep purple
un la grosse défonce légué les grosses
d'un gris et finalement je m'aperçois
qu'il a vécu la même chose mais il s'en
tire superbe il est originaire c'est un
bel âge pour un ensemble d'outils
connais les quadragénaires c'est un
vieux berger des quadragénaires ue pour
le mois 41,1 à une époque quand même
vous vous aviez un ange gardien avec
vous qui s'appelait aident et qui était
un ancien bar un ancien drogué qui vous
suivait partout et c est ce que vous
l'avez toujours non j'ai parlé récemment
avec nos habitats détruits dans le
michigan en tournée avec moi une fois
mais pas tous sont partis depuis c'est
quelqu'un de bien surtout quand je suis
retourné précisément c'est pas mal
d'étapes d'avoir un copain avec soin
hélène ségara ségara je connais pas
[Applaudissements]
hélène ségara when she was you me and
she was a team of the view mais orlando
lui a demandé de chanter autre chose que
du depeche mode mais en plus il avait un
vrai look
tu vois il s'appelle pas comme ça par
hasard ils veulent des années 80 et de
tout ce qu'ils ont emporté tout bien on
va y voit la mort d' annoncer ses chiens
qu'est ce que tu fais et lucas tu fais
un chat mais j'ai dit c'est parce que il
ya ma fille m'a demandé de dessiner à
achat alors j'ai décidé à chaki ceux qui
se shootent avec une seringue dans
laquelle il ya des souris ainsi ils sont
un peu durs appelé l on peut dire à
passer dans l'hémicycle en tous les cas
en parlant de sa dette gagnent quand
vous repensez maintenant à cette époque
c'est-à-dire à los angeles quand vous
vous étiez lacéré les poignets avec une
lame de rasoir
quand vous pensez à l'overdose que vous
avez fait au speed ball au sunset
marquis hôtel berlinois mais je me
rappelle pas tout ça mais enfin quand
vous pensez à ça aujourd'hui à cette
époque de ces parties de bons parcours
de ma vie que je peux dire c'étaient des
choix que j'ai fait à l'époque quand on
en fait trop
comme pour tous c'est vrai que vous êtes
mort pendant savez que vous êtes membre
en deux minutes quand vous avez fait
cette overdose aux 67 marquer
effectivement je crois que j'étais
on m'a emmené à l'hosto je fais le home
a dit ça après coup effectivement je ne
le savais pas sur le moment j'ai frôlé
et c'est ce genre d'histoire un petit
peu rasoir mais ce qu'à l'époque je me
rendais comme je faisais je me disais
débile mais il a fallu que j'arrive à ce
stade là pour me rendre compte de la
bêtise que je faisais je me rendais
compte que c'était débile
et jusque là je ferai que je m'amusais
mais c'était pas c'était pas très bien
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez dire
aux gens qui vous regardent aux gens qui
nous regardent que la drogue c'est sympa
au départ qu'on en prend pour être bien
et puis qu au bout d'un mois deux mois
trois mois on en prend juste pour pas
être mal et que ça devient un enfer
qu'on recompte les problèmes avec
l'alcool
y a pas su faire la différence la drogue
qu'on dise des choses qui paraissent
acceptables au départ et puis qui
entraîne des problèmes par la suite
justement à cause des excès chez moi je
me suis mais là tu publiquement contre
la drogue
mon combat était publique et et j'ai
voulu effectivement l'aide du public
dans tout ce que je peux espérer c'est
que aujourd'hui moi même je puisse faire
quelque chose de positif par rapport à
tout ça j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
encore là à faire de la musique
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me suis lancé là dedans au départ
j'ai la chance d'avoir eu une deuxième
chance de chance de m'en sortir je crois
qu'il faut pouvoir demander de l'aide
quel engagement c'est la chose la plus
difficile qu'ils ont un passé moi j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir autour de moi des
gens qui travaillaient pour voir avec
moi quelques vrais amis mon manager de
la funk il a aussi qui m'a aidé
[Musique]